get ready to ugly cry Marvel fans and
beware major Avengers infinity war
spoilers ahead
guardians of the galaxy director James
Gunn has shared a heart shattering
detail about Groot and infinity war that
has people absolutely reeling on Twitter
Gunn revealed the tree-like Guardians
final line in the film uttered just
after Josh Brolin's Thanos snaps his
Infinity Gauntlet rocking hand to get
rid of half of the universe's population
grew voiced by Fast and the Furious
franchise star Vin Diesel was one of the
heroes that disintegrated into a flurry
of ashy space pits joined by a number of
others including chadwick boseman z--
Black Panther Benedict Cumberbatch's
Doctor Strange Elizabeth Olsen
Scarlet Witch and Tom Hollands
spider-man who had what was largely
considered the most agonizing and
tear-inducing final moment in infinity
war until now a fan asked Gunn on
Twitter might be too soon to ask this
but do you know what groots last line is
at the end of the movie surprisingly
Gunn answered quickly and candidly
disclosing that groots last word was
dead in reference to Bradley Cooper's
Rocket Raccoon we are Groot we are
broken and we're not alone one Twitter
user responded to gun that Groot and
Rocket devastated my heart and soul I
have never imagined a time where a
talking tree calling a talking raccoon
dad would be this much on ironically sad
Marvel what have you done to us when
asked about it Gunn reiterated that the
line was in the screenplay and that he
didn't make up the answer to the fan on
the spot
the script in question is the exclusive
group version that only goes to Gunn in
diesel so we'll have to take the
directors tweet reveal at face value
while Avengers infinity war continues to
blaze through box office records
recently passing the 1 billion dollar
milestone in record time will be quietly
sobbing in the corner about all this
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]